talking of celebrity fans about  Christine Baranski our great actor  Michael Sheen do you know Michael Sheen  do you know you don't know what he seems  to know me  yes so explain the Michael Sheen  connection this is good you like do you  know this Cher  no this is good well I know nothing I  think Sarah Silverman was quoted as  saying that Michael Sheen it's hard for  me to say this but Michael Sheen refers  to his penis as the great christine  baranski  [Laughter]  [Applause]  long lasting career Oh No yeah reliable  reliable Collinson I mean you can go  anywhere it's to haunt me all the time I  really want to meet Michael stealing  what were you thinking yeah next time  you know several  [Music]